Valentina buenas noches para entender la
anulación de la candidatura de Carlos
Pineda el candidato que lideraba las
encuestas de presidenciales aquí en
Guatemala que se había vuelto muy viral
por cuenta de sus redes en tiktok
empresario de aeronaves hay que
remitirse al mes de noviembre de 2022 el
mes del año pasado en el que su partido
prosperidad ciudadana debía realizar una
asamblea en la cual se pudiera elegir a
un comité ejecutivo de este partido para
también proclamar la candidatura de este
candidato sin embargo ante el tribunal
supremo electoral esa asamblea se estaba
realizando en Unas fechas extemporáneas
y no podía entonces Carlos Pineda lograr
esa candidatura pero la sala quinta de
lo contencioso administrativo falló a
favor de celebrar esta asamblea se pudo
realizar y luego vino una segunda
impugnación por parte de uno de los
miembros del interior del partido quien
dijo que se estaban imponiendo a la
fuerza los candidatos presidenciales
pero el tribunal supremo electoral no
aceptó esa denuncia por considerar la
extemporánea pero sí meses después
aceptó la denuncia de un otro partido el
partido cambio de la familia valdison
una familia política empresarial muy
importante de Guatemala que otroramente
tuvo unas denuncias de lavado de dinero
por parte de los Estados Unidos y con
quien se tienen relaciones muy
cuestionadas con Carlos Pineda de manera
que se puede llegar a hablar de una
venganza electoral aquí en Guatemala
Aunque es un tema espinoso y hay que
mirar con mucha lupa la candidatura de
Carlos Pineda organismos internacionales
como human right watch denunciaron que
se trata de una Clara
instrumentalización del poder judicial
para garantizar un resultado electoral y
la Unión Europea dijo que ve con suma
preocupación que en Guatemala se están
expulsando arbitrariamente las
candidaturas presidenciales porque con
la de Pineda ya van tres
recta final de las elecciones
presidenciales cómo queda el ajedrez
político de los principales candidatos
para suceder a yamaté
bueno la primera en la lista es Sandra
Torres ella es ex primera dama de la
nación estuvo casada con Álvaro Colón y
se divorció de él como requisito de ley
para poder lanzar su propia candidatura
a la presidencia Álvaro Colón recordemos
que fue un presidente que estuvo preso
por hechos de corrupción ahora bien el
problema con Sandra Torres es que ha
llegado dos veces a segunda vuelta en
Guatemala en las elecciones con Jimmy
Morales perdió también en las elecciones
con la Alejandro yamaté y aquí se dice
que es la candidata más conocida en todo
el país pero la que carga más fuerza de
anti voto lo que se podría llegar a
pronosticar es que sí va a llegar a
segunda vuelta y allí Quien llegue a
segunda vuelta puede ser o bien edmon
mulette o bien Suri Ríos no muy
conocidos Pero cualquiera de estos dos
candidatos puede llegar a sostener la
segunda vuelta con Sandra Torres y poder
ser el nuevo presidente de